this is what you're talking about it's
called Euler's identity sorry what do I
say here okay um what are the numbers
for the nomas first he he is 2.718 ooh
it's it's an important constant it has
to do exponential growth exponential
growth things that are that grow really
fast and faster and faster and faster
they never slow down okay they grow the
speed that they grow at is more to how
big they are so think of it kind of like
this is a really tell me
but imagine if as you've got bigger like
if you get fatter right your mouth gets
bigger so you can eat more stuff and get
fatter fast that no it doesn't and he's
not hurt much but anyway that's kind of
what this graph is like right as he gets
bigger he eats more and as he eats more
and gets bigger he can eat faster anyway
that's what that numbers about I I is
the square root of negative 1 that's a
weird number
you're like it doesn't equal anything
well it does we call it I write and you
know apply this you're familiar with
that I'm thinking about Python you all
used to think about it to do with circle
areas and circumference --is right but
you will you'll learn soon enough that
it's also a way of measuring it's a
number that's useful in measuring angles
if you don't use degrees if you use a
different kind of unit anyway the angle
that it represents that you would be
familiar with is 180 degrees okay it's
just that we use different units to
describe it anyway
therefore what does he see me well if
you learn enough pieces of um of algebra
and calculus and trigonometry and other
weird things you will learn now what
this thing means is it's about rotation
it's about going around and around the
corner vectors right so here this one
that's an angle of 0 I'm on the axis
right so if I went up this far what
angle would that be that would be 90
degrees right and if I went this far
that would be a hundred eighty degrees
or it would be pi and the unit record is
radians okay now if you're around that
far you end up here but what are the
coordinates of that spot that spot is
negative one zero now about probably 75%
that doesn't make sense to you because
you don't have the records of pieces
that make sense on why this is equal to
this and why this is equal to this and
why this means rotation okay but that's
the short answer
so you're you I'm trying to build a
house in the air with no comment